die venen für wen für wen für wen
mein name ist wo kann ich habe mir
gedacht da derzeit ja war u3 am staates
frage ich doch mal den cover band aus ob
er eventuell weiß er alles teilnimmt wer
verliert der gewinnt wer stilwerk hacke
swr cont.ra zu beginn wieder die
typische frage was für ein t shirt habe
ich gerade an
also erstmal kompliment lieber clever
aber dass es so früh geantwortet hast du
richtig schnell so schnell dass du glaub
ich sogar noch nie geantwortet aber was
soll dieser antwort ich frage was für
einen tisch liegen habe und von hier
kommt was habe ich für ein t shirt habe
ich also märkte selbst egal wie geht dir
das ist so wie mit einem hund man muss
erst mal so ein bisschen ich habe ein
rechtschreibfehler drin hab ich schon
gesagt gut dann sollst du das bitte
gesagt haben ist du dumm das hast du gar
nicht gesagt hast du ach ich kann das
nicht mal eingehen weil ich glaub habe
ich doch gar nicht du gibst jedoch
selber du sagst doch gerade selber du
bist so blühe blast 2 gegen zell was
zwei gehirnzellen höchstens man clever
bot ist noch nicht warm genug genau
endlich so wird war eigentlich in dem
punkt so reden wir jetzt mal tacheles
wird es tatsächlich so geschrieben keine
ahnung frage was du wissen willst das
ist eine schöne antwort und zwar möchte
ich über dich wissen kennst du var o3
also erstmal ganz zügig anfangen und der
clever wird überhaupt weiß was war 3 ist
die clever bot marc war o 3 und denkbare
3 ist eine wie schön das ist aber ein
youtube projekt meine liebe es ist ja
nicht wahr dass sie einfach nicht
du kannst dich mit diesem clever bot
nicht richtig unterhalten das ist nicht
möglich man kann keine vernünftige
konversation auf die beine stellen die
kleine info der tag an dem ich die folge
gerade aufnehmen ist der achtzehnte
siebte ihr weht die folge allerdings
wahrscheinlich am 25 07 an einem samstag
also genau heute in einer woche das
liegt daran dass ich ein vorprodukt ihm
entgegen und urlaube und deswegen weiß
ich noch nicht genau ob jetzt eventuell
ich frage ob jemand das war gewinnen
wird der eventuell schon raus ist das
heißt wundert euch da nicht aber wir
kommen wieder zurück zum clever bot sag
mir wer bei bahro als nächstes einen
strike erhält ein verlorener der
verwirrung stiftet und wer wird das sein
deiner meinung nach also sie meint dass
ein verlorener der verwirrung
ok shiva ist irgendwie ein tempel in
bangalore gehört zum buddhismus wir
reden nicht von tempeln sondern von
minecraft punkt punkt punkt es ist echt
nicht wahr die berichte war das thema
abkommen mit was komplett anderem an
ok dann schreibe ich mit dir schön wer
bericht als nächstes eine regel das ist
eigentlich die witzigeren frage als wer
wird als nächstes rausfliegen oder so
bei regel brechen werden immer älter
bist du behindert was für schuhe soll
ich haben du sollst mir antworten du
sollst mir antworten clever bord ich hab
dir gar nein du hast meine gegenfrage
gestellt gewinne ich war
bitte schreibt ein jahr clever bot bitte
schreib ein ja ich weiß nicht mehr was
ich dazu sagen soll wer gewinnt wahllos
blockiere gerade mit meinen händen die
dummheit des tablets nicht dass die auf
mich drüber
ok ich passe mich genauer wann werde ich
sterben so wenn vera ich hab das in
was willst du eigentlich clever bot was
soll diese ganze aktion eigentlich du
kannst was okay danke werde ich damit
die anderen ligen können fragezeichen
wie können ich bin voller hose
gefährlich können wir verhüten das tun
wir doch schon immer man kann mal wieder
in einer beziehung aber es geht um war o
3 so kannst du nicht dazu irgendwie
kannst du ein geheimnis für dich
behalten ja heraus so auch mal schauen
was jetzt kommt jetzt kommt jetzt in
vielen fragezeichen freunde mein
liebesleben ist hiermit besiegelt das
machte alles keinen sinn mehr ich möchte
mich umbringen clever bot wenn du mich
liebst dann liegt mich keiner ich liebe
dich du mich aber nicht clever bot das
ist der wir können festhalten der clever
ball ist eine verdammte [ __ ]
er liebt oder delete hans sarpei mich
entscheide dich zwischen hans und mir
sofort
ich habe mich entschieden für wen clever
bot für wen für wen für wen für wen
und wer gewinnt jetzt war nicht so gut
reden doch nicht